[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain an american science fiction film
called the time machine
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
the premise of the film is set in 1899.
dr alexander hartigan is an associate
professor of applied mechanics and
engineering at columbia university the
movie starts as we see him working on a
formula so much invested that his friend
and colleague david philby has to remind
him of his date with his girlfriend emma
at 5. hearing this alexander quickly
picks his notes and rushes back to his
house to get ready on his way he and
david talk about all of alex's proposals
that the university has rejected david
suggests he make his proposals less
radical for them to make them useful for
humans at alex's home they are greeted
by his housekeeper mrs watchit they make
alex get into fancy new clothes and he
leaves to meet emma he finally meets
emma the two walk in the central park
talking
alex brings up his deteriorating health
and claims he will only be good again
when she marries him emma with teary
eyes accepts his proposal
after a little hassling through his
pockets he gives her a ring with her
birthstone embedded in it emma is over
the moon
however a man suddenly approaches them
in circles around
he asks them for their money when alex
tries to retaliate the mugger points his
gun at him
alex complies and gives the mugger his
wallet and watch but when he asks for
emma's ring they deny it the man then
tries to snatch it from her and shoots
her dead while struggling alex holds her
in his arms calling her name while she
takes her last breath and dies he is
beyond devastated as he hugs her limp
corpse and cries in vain the scene cuts
to four years later alex is writing a
formula on the board researching
something like he always does
he has still not been able to get over
emma's death and has been busy with his
work ever since
david and mrs watch it are worried for
him that day when david comes to meet
him he notices something on the other
side of the curtains and demands david
to tell him what he is working on
david invites him for dinner in a week
and offers to show him his invention
then a week goes by and it is finally
the day alex dresses himself up for the
first time since emma's death he then
opens the curtains and we see a piece of
huge machinery on the other side
it has many wheels and gears in the
middle a chair is embedded alex sits on
it and looks at emma's picture on a
locket he slowly pulls down a lever
making a sphere shield around him the
machine then puts itself in motion
when alex pulls down a final lever the
camera zooms into a pocket watch and we
see its hand move in an anti-clockwise
direction
as it turns out the machine alex is
using as a time machine he has put his
blood and sweat into the machine to go
back to the day emma died four years ago
and save her
in the following scene we see the future
alex in central park on the day of
emma's death
she sees him and runs towards him alex
is stunned to see his precious love back
he kisses her in delight and runs her to
the nearest chariot to take her away
from the park
they get off the chariot in the middle
of the city alex tells her to go to her
home and stay there for the night
assuming that the past alex will come to
emma's home at night he tells her to not
be confused and just remember that he
loves her he leaves her by the side of
the road to get her flowers as he
promised but then a vehicle hits her
killing emma again
alex realizes that he cannot change
emma's fate and no matter what he does
she will die that night but he doesn't
give up
he believes that the people from the
future have surely found a way to alter
this factor so he decides to go into the
future and study futuristic time
machines
he gets into the machine and pulls down
the lever again this time setting the
time to 20 30. as he travels through
time he sees the world around him
changing
in 2030 he sees an advertisement for a
settlement being established on the moon
he goes to the new york library hoping
to find a book on time travel where he
meets a hologram of the librarian named
vox 114 and is stunned by the technology
however when he talks about time travel
vox 114 reveals that there hasn't been
any invention of such sort thinking that
he would have better luck a couple of
years later he gets into the machine
again and now travels to the year 2037.
in 2037 the world has been fully
destroyed the lunar habitation program
has made the earth inhabitable because
the moon was pulled closer to it the
gravitational forces of the bodies
change causing frequent earthquakes and
tsunamis on earth the lunar habitation
has caused a huge crack on the surface
of the moon
two policemen who are evacuating the
earth arrest alex to take him to his
evacuation center as he resists them the
ground starts to shake and splits in
half spilling out hot lava alex quickly
gets into his machine and drives away
but amidst the chaos hits his head on a
piece of metal making him go unconscious
the time machine starts its journey but
an unconscious alex isn't there to stop
it when he finally opens his eyes he
sees that he has reached the year 800
2701 and quickly stops the machine
before falling unconscious again
he wakes up in a bed with his wounds
healed
as he wears his clothes a little boy
approaches him and runs away alex
follows the kid and sees that the future
humans have reverted to a primitive
lifestyle and live on cliffs they all
come to alex and watch him in awe but do
not seem to understand english except
for a girl named mara who can speak the
language fluently alex tells her that he
is a time traveler but mara tells the
others he is just a wandering fool so
that they won't kill him
those people are called the eloise a
loud honking is hurt and everyone goes
into their shed
that night he stays at mara and her
brother kailyn's place he sees the
broken pieces of the moon in the sky
the following day mara takes alex to his
time machine
the two see that it has not been damaged
mara insists alex take kailyn with him
to the past before alex can ask why loud
honking is hurt in the background
mara freaks out and runs to save kalyn
as a confused alex follows her
everyone around them starts running back
to the cliffs as well
suddenly alex comes face to face with a
beast life creature
they are called the morlocks
more of them emerge from the ground and
start attacking everyone they tie the
people they can get their hands in and
take them into the ground
alex watches as one of them gets mara
and sinks with her into the soil when
all of them are gone alex tries asking
the others where the morlocks take them
but kailyn tells him that when the
eloise are taken they are not supposed
to talk about it caitlyn then takes alex
to the opening to the world of the
morlocks
they climb down into a cave and alex
realizes that it is the new york library
the hologram of vox 144 talks from
behind them
since the technology worked on solar
power he has survived all these years
alex is beyond surprised and asks him
what is going on with the world now
vox 114 replies that the human race has
evolved into two eloise and morlocks
this is the nature of the world now
the morlocks come to the surface to hunt
eloise for survival
vox then reveals that to reach the world
of morlocks they should follow the
breathing kaelin and alex hear the noise
and follow it to reach a massive statue
of a demonic face whose mouth is an
opening to morlock's world
he leaves kailyn outside and climbs down
underground carefully he finally reaches
the place and sees a whole civilization
there he then sneaks into a room and
accidentally falls into a pond full of
human remains
alex is then found by a morlock and sent
into their leader's chamber
the leader explains that when the moon
dissociated some people sank under the
ground with nowhere else to go
over the years they evolved into flesh
eating more locks
others miraculously survived on the
surface and repopulated the eloise the
morlocks tried to come back to the
surface but couldn't because of the
years of underground evolution so they
started to hunt the humans from the
surface for food and breeding the leader
also reveals that he has the power to
control both eloise and warlock's minds
and controls the balance of the world
through them he has also read alex's
mind and knows that he is a time
traveler and his desire is to bring emma
back
he makes alex hallucinate about his life
if emma hadn't died he is filled with
sadness to see emma and his kid playing
the leader then concludes that humans
cannot change fate because they are the
results of their own actions
then he shows alex the time machine that
he had brought into the morlock world
the leader wants him to go back to where
he came from and not harm the balance of
the society now
alex quietly obliges but as he starts
the machine he pulls the leader in with
him the two struggle for a while alex
holds him outside the machine's sphere
and starts it the leader dies rapidly by
aging he again stops the machine in the
future and sees the places filled with
morlock's cave suggesting that the place
is now ruled by morlocks
alex then comes back to save mara and
brings her out of the cage the morlocks
get angry and leave to attack them but
alex jams a gear in the machine creating
a massive distortion in time
the time machine explodes taking all of
morlock's world with it but mara alex
managed to run out of the cave just in
time
with his time machine gone alex decides
to stay with eloise as he has found
satisfaction here in the future we see
vox 144 teaching eloise children about
the past of humans alex brings mara and
kalyn to the place where his lab used to
be as he talks to them somewhere in
another time david and mrs watch it
enter alex's lab and discuss his
disappearance david claims that alex is
happy wherever he is and offers mrs
watchit to come work as his housekeeper
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching